I'm Carly taken from mr. robot and this
is my Google autocomplete interview the
interview who is Carly shaken I'm Carly
jaqen how tall is Carly jaqen with heels
and like six feet tall without heels I'm
5'4
how old is Carly chicken I don't know
like 25 just earned 25 how much is Carly
chicken worth I I like want to be humble
but at the same time I just want to
admit that I like it it's like five
billion dollars does mr. robot exist No
does mr. robot get better no we're just
getting it get so much better I can't
get better it's amazing but it does get
better
does mr. robot have schizophrenia
debatable does mr. robot have a second
season yes we do it is actually airing
July 13th on USA does mr. robot does mr.
roberto's robot is deliver yeah he does
how is mr. robot not real I don't know
he's just like not how accurate is mr.
robot scariest part of the show is that
it is completely accurate and everything
that happens on the show can happen in
real life so don't you know close your
eyes at night how is mr. robot like
Fight Club Brad Pitt plays mr. robot
it's like the whole same cast so is f
society real 100% is f society based on
anonymous I think it they're inspired
inspired by them is abscess ayat e & le
it's head I don't know as of right now
no but who knows will hackers oh this is
good
will hackers ever be stopped no try and
stop them they'll hack you will hackers
be expelled from where school will
hackers win the battle yeah they will
will hackers save the world
yeah they will will hackers rule the
world
yeah they will can mr. robot happen
in real life I don't know what that
means
can someone have an imaginary dead
father appear yeah
can there be a real-life Society and
take down corporate America yeah
can I trust mr. robot yeah he's a really
trustworthy guy actually and I think you
would be wise to do so